hardin and millsap going to the sixers
ben simmons seth curry andre drummond
and picks going
brooklyn's way so how did this all shake
out chris
well i think this was something the
brooklyn nets felt they needed to do i
was following the nets for the last
three weeks doing sidelines for tnt and
just talking with the players on that
next team and looking at their body
language they were exhausted the james
harden saga had wear it on them and it
was it got to a point where it was
affecting their play on the basketball
court because
they knew that he wasn't all in and you
guys know that you know once you have a
prominent figure on the roster
that has they don't feel like they're
getting this all it has an effect on the
rest of the team so i think the brooklyn
nets felt like this was something that
they couldn't
keep over their heads for the rest of
this season and so they made a deal got
ben simmons ben simmons gets a fresh
start i spoke to rich paul ben simmons
agent
he's looking forward to the opportunity
he already spoke with kevin durant and
kyrie irving and he's looking forward to
it they're going to take some time to
get him acclimated but both sides james
harden and ben simmons is getting a
fresh new start and uh i think it was
more beneficial than doing it now
opposed to doing it in the off season
because i was told by front office
rivals that
there were possibly going to be some
complaints about tampering because um
james hart is so close to sixers
co-owner michael rubin and they felt
like um there was gonna possibly be some
backdoor channels that were
being going down so uh you know it may
just made it all the system world to
kind of get this deal done now and so
we'll see what happens steve nash was
asked a question the other day well
james hard to be traded he replied no so
was this trade a shocker to james harden
or did he know or did him and his agent
know he was getting traded
i i don't know if they knew for sure but
obviously they knew that things were in
the work for a few days right now and
again i was around his next
net pain for the last three weeks they
kept downplaying the fact that
uh james harden did not want to leave uh
when everybody else was hearing
otherwise they kept saying that he wants
you committed to the organization so
that was a talking point that they were
trying to relay to everybody and they
were down playing all the hoopla that
was coming out but it was serious hoopla
you know james did one out
um you know he he just didn't feel the
fit was was right for his talents at
that time and you feel like this is the
best move for him in his career right
now
you know chris this is a fascinating
trade in my opinion i have zero idea
what's going to happen
i don't know how embiid
and harden gonna fit together because
james the dominant ball guy
embiid is a great dominant i mean he's
the mvp so far but also you flip it to
brooklyn
you got ben who won't shoot
you've got kyrie who's only going to
play in half the games
how is that thing going to work with
with with uh when kd comes back
like it's going to be fast he's really
in some games he's going to be one on i
mean joe harris is going to come back
but in a lot of games it's really going
to be one on five
yeah chuck we still don't know if joe
harris is gonna come back this season
he's still um looking at
how he's going to handle his ankle
injury but with that being said i think
the brooklyn nets feel like look we get
an all-star player obviously this is an
all-star player that has deficiency on
the offensive end but we get him in a
guy that
wants to be there most importantly and a
guy that's going to be able to play as
soon as they get him acclimated i think
if they they looked at the landscape of
the league and
realized that this was their best option
this was the best option that they had
out there and it didn't make sense to
make a move in the offseason and you got
to give brooklyn credit for you know
they got andre drummond seth curry uh
they wanted matisse bible in there as
well um you know i spoke to um
bible's agent aaron goodman and aaron
goodwin and eric goodwin and you know
they were on
sean markson and elton brand
of the sixers and making sure that look
after you sure you want to do this this
is the uh you know number one and you
know statistically the number one
defender in the league and um so the
sixers were able to keep uh bible out of
that deal so
it's going to be tough i don't know if
this um propels the nets to like making
that next step but it's definitely a
player that they can work with not just
in this season but next season to try to
make that championship push and it
eliminates the distractions chris i
don't know if you've asked the uh execs
uh at either spot this question
especially in brooklyn
is this a next year move
if you're thinking of brooklyn because
if you're looking at
winning a championship this was that was
the thing that was supposed to happen
this year in brooklyn
and now you have a guy like charles says
he's gonna
can only play in half the games the ones
only on the road you have a guy who
hasn't played in a half a season or more
three quarters of a season
so you have another your best player who
is actually hasn't played in the last 10
15 games so is this a next year move as
you ask that question or is it wait no
we're going for the championship this
year
i think i think you have to be realistic
um when you're talking about a
championship this year is it possible
yes it is possible but you have to work
ben simmons into the fold that's going
to take weeks
maybe a month we don't know how long
it's going to take for him to get back
in the fold and not just get back into
the fold get back to playing all-star
being centered type of level of
basketball
we they don't know what's going to
happen with the new york city mandate on
the vaccine if kyrie if that lift if
that restriction will be lifted if kyrie
will be able to play in home game so
there's a lot to cover there to answer
your question kenny i think you have to
look into next season and say okay i
think the situation with kyrie will be
resolved at that point ben simmons will
be up to form at that point you gotta
look towards the future now the problem
you have with james harden is you really
couldn't look for the future because i
think if things would have gone really
haywire
this season you know just having james
harden on that team this whole season
everybody knows he's not bought in
everybody knows he's a few months away
from departing and then they knew that
definitely he wasn't coming back next
season so i think this is a move for the
future for the next one more thing on
this trade and then we'll move on
you talk about
ben simmons acclimating
i can understand that new system etc but
from talking to rich paul do you get the
impression that emotionally ben simmons
could play right now
i don't know the answer to that ernie um
to be honest with you i will say this
you know he's still going to be you know
seeing his therapist and trying to get
himself mentally right but definitely
this is a breath of fresh air for him
he's like he's lost a lot of money as
you guys know with the fines and
everything and not playing and this is a
this is a huge weight off the shoulder
so him going into a fresh start
and playing for for for a player and and
teams that he's that he trusts he feels
like he trusts them right now and that's
the big thing with ben trust is really
big but he has a small inner circle
and that's due to because he doesn't
trust a lot of people so he feels like
this is this is everything is moving in
the right direction and so you know i
expect being like i said i expected to
take some time um get back in the form
get back to acclimated but definitely
mentally
this move right here i think is going to
expedite that process and hopefully can
get out there sooner than later let's
take a look at